on this episode of AI adventures we will
attempt to go through an entire machine
learning workflow in one video
pulling best practices from our previous
episodes it's a bit of material but I
think we can do it training a model with
the end this data set is often
considered the hello world of machine
learning but that's been done many times
over and unfortunately just because a
model does well on M NIST is not
necessarily predictive of high
performance with other datasets
especially since most image data we have
today are more complex than handwritten
digits delando decided it was time to
make n this fashionable again and
recently released a data set called
fashion amnesty it's the exact same
format as the regular m missed except
the data is in the form of pictures of
various clothing types shoes bags it's
still crossed in categories though and
the images are still 28 by 28 pixels so
let's train a model to detect which type
of clothing is being shown we'll start
by building a linear classifier as usual
and see how we do and we'll use
tensorflow as estimator framework to
make our code easy to write and easy to
maintain
as a reminder we'll first load in the
data create our classifier and then run
the training and evaluation we'll also
make some predictions directly from our
local model let's start by creating our
model we'll flatten that data set from
being 28 by 28 to 1 by 784 pixels and
make a feature column called pixels this
is analogous to our flower features from
episode 3
plain and simple estimators next we'll
create our linear classifier we have 10
different possible classes to label
instead of the three that we used
previously with the iris flowers to run
our training we'll need to set up our
data set and input function tensorflow
has a built-in utility to accept a numpy
array and generate an input function
right from that so let's take advantage
of it we're loading our data set using
the input data module I've already
downloaded the day set to a folder so
we'll point to that here now we can call
classifier trained to bring together our
classifier the input function and the
data set finally we run an evaluation
step to see how our model did when we
use the classic and this data set this
linear model typically gets about nine
the 1% accuracy however fashion and this
is a considerably more complex data set
and we can only really achieve an
accuracy in the low 80s and sometimes
even lower than that so how can we do
better as we learn in episode 6 let's go
deep swapping in the DNN classifier is a
one-line change and we can now rerun our
training and evaluation to see if our
deep neural network can perform any
better than the linear one and as we
discussed in episode 5 we should bring
up tensor board to take a look at these
two models performance side by side it
looks like the deep network could
definitely use some more time to Train
though estimators makes this easy all we
need to do is rerun the call to the
train and evaluate functions looking at
tester board it seems like my deep model
is performing no better than my linear
no one did this is perhaps an
opportunity however to tune some of my
hyper parameters like we talked about in
Episode two
maybe my model needs to be larger to
accommodate the complexity of this data
set or perhaps my learning rate needs to
be lowered experimenting with these
parameters a bit we can finally break
through and achieve a higher overall
accuracy than our linear model can
obtain it takes quite a bit more
training but ultimately this is worth it
to achieve those higher accuracy numbers
notice also that the linear model
plateaus earlier than the deep network
because deep networks are often more
complex than linear ones they can take
longer to Train and at this stage say
we're happy with our model we'd be able
to export it and produce a scalable
fashion M this classifier API you can
see episode 4 for more details on how to
do that let's also take a quick peek at
how you can make predictions using
estimators in large part it looks just
like how we called train and evaluate
that's one of the great things about
estimators the consistent interface
notice that this time we've specified a
batch size of 1 num epochs of 1 and
shuffle is false this is because we want
the predictions to go one by one making
predictions through all the data and
preserving that order I've extracted
five images from the middle of the
evaluation data set for us to try some
predictions on and I picked these five
just because they were in the middle but
because we my model managed to get two
of them wrong
both were supposed to be shirts but the
model thought that the third example was
a bag and the fifth example was a coat
incorrectly and you can see we're
looking at these images how these
examples are more challenging than
handwritten numbers if for no other
reason than just the graininess of the
images so how did your model perform and
what parameters did you end up using to
achieve that accuracy let me know below
in the comments you can find the code
that I use to train this model and
generate these images also in the links
below along with more links to the other
resources we talked about in this
episode our next set of videos will be
focused on some of the tools of the
machine learning ecosystem to help you
build out your workflow and torch it as
well as showcase even more architectures
that you can employ to solve your
machine learning problems I look forward
to seeing you there
and until then keep on machine learning
thanks for watching this episode of
cloudy AI adventures be sure to
subscribe to the channel to catch future
episodes right when they come out